Shayne Lynn and Mark yuan have spent the
last two years planning their wedding in
fine detail the cake shop owners from
Taipei have been dreaming of their
special day since 2017 when Taiwan's top
court ruled same-sex couples should be
allowed to marry
Taiwan may often be overlooked
internationally and all the things we
have done are visionaries we can be
proud of that but on top of the usual
wedding stresses Shan mark and other
Taiwanese same-sex couples have a bigger
problem support for the issue is divided
three different bills were tabled for
Friday's vote but only one used the word
marriage put forward by the government
it allows same-sex couples similar
rights as married heterosexual couples a
bill satisfactory for the LGBT rights
campaigners the other versions backed by
conservative lawmakers were void of the
term marriage not everyone on this
relatively liberal Island shares these
people's desire for equality in a series
of referendums last year more than
two-thirds of voters decided marriage
should only be defined as being between
a man and a woman numbers that opponents
of same-sex marriage say cannot be
ignored let's go straight now to DW s
William yang standing by for us in
Taipei with the latest good morning to
you William this is a first for Asia
what are some of the reactions to this
law that you're getting where you are
[Applause]
[Music]
so we're just now hearing all the
supporters of synthetics marriage
chanting and cheering at the background
because the legislature just passed the
third reading of the government's
commitment legislative bill so this
means that Taiwan becomes the first
country in Asia through the legalized
same-sex marriage and also some man the
title without any one continue to be the
gay couple in Asia okay what about the
referendum last November that rejected
same-sex marriage we heard about in our
report how did that play into the debate
and the voting today so as we know last
year's referendum result show
overwhelming need a people's support the
fact that they want the marriage to be
defined as a union between a man and a
woman however the ruling party steps
step up their game and decided to apply
by the Constitutional Court's rule which
is that it is unconstitutional to ban
same-sex marriage
so this bill just proves the political
policies here is progressing in a way
that human rights is being considered as
a very important issue in Taiwan okay
for those who support the same-sex
marriage
aside are they happy with the way the
bill was passed with its wording and his
provisions
as today's voting up - for today's
voting start there have been some
concerns about the effectiveness of this
bill of friends infant sex couples the
right to get married the organizers have
repeatedly say that this is already a
watered down version of the bill that
they can accept so they likely will
continue to push more for marriage right
in the future and there's election
coming up so since X marriage is likely
to continue remain a very important
topic in discussion here in Taiwan boy
yang for us in Taipei William thank you
very much for bringing us up today